philadelphia pennsylvania get ready
because the are you garbage boys are
coming home the roost oh yeah october
27th we're gonna be at helium comedy
club get your tickets now i promise you
if i ever lied to you before this
puppy's gonna sell out and we don't want
you to miss it yeah don't be left out in
the cold guys it's gonna be a good time
some live stand-up with me foley t-bone
maybe a special guest who knows and then
we play live ayg with the crowds when
you get there you submit your questions
it's a good time see you there welcome
to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
ru garbage sure is it's a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out they grew up to be
classy yeah or if they're just a big old
piece of trash oh baby i'm your host
dave foley coming at you on a beautiful
day
down here aunt toddy's basement yeah
caught her getting ready for work this
morning
a sight i cannot unsee oh boy but i got
something to tell you
sucks first socks first socks first on
tutti so she's on the winning team
that's not a scott's first gang that's
not a good team to be on if you're on
todd's team my co-host is coming at you
from
right across the table at me this is a
family episode yeah he's looking very
european today i don't get it did you
have your foreskin put back on what's
going on it grew back on its own
actually
like a skin tag
it's like a newt you cut its tail off it
keeps coming back two of them grow
if i could be so lucky
would you take one big wiener or two
little wieners what if you had two
little weenies i mean i got one little
one now so i'll tell you i'll double the
pleasure
i mean what are we talking about here
kippy you look very european in that
uh yeah okay sure very stylish very cool
very swag you should be drinking those
weird bottles of water they have over
there sure an orangina here that's big
in europe hey you're big everywhere all
right kevin james ryan god damn it hey
gang happy to be here thanks for tuning
in as always please make sure you rate
view subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube and as you know
those numbers are true true the [ __ ]
roof baby cooking closing on 30 thou
over there look out and then
obviously i would be a [ __ ] jerk off
an [ __ ] a piece of [ __ ] a dummy say
it if i don't shout out the greatest
website of all time patreon.com are you
garbage good lord hope give me your hand
for one second
dear lord in heaven please watch over mr
jack conte and mr sam yam and their
families
for all that they have done for us
love that money dear lord baby jesus
sweet little house for everyone at
patreon.com amen even down to the
janitors baby shout out to patreon.com
it takes a village to support a fat guy
i'll tell you that
and how about a nice quick shout out to
our producer extraordinaire the magic
man makes us all look good give it up
for t-bone mcmuffin it's our good pal
toby mcmullen what's up dudes hey boom
oof we got a i'm so happy to be back
although we do have an admission to the
fans out there what we went down to
texas and we stepped out we changed it
up
we're bucky's family now bucky's fam and
well listen when i'm up when i'm up top
but when i'm on the top shelf of the
other country
i'm going wah-wah all day long if i'm in
the northeast corridor wow you get down
there in tejas get down there tay haas
got down there in the bible belt you got
to mix in a little bit i got my boots
all my spurs my jingle jangles the 10
gallon hat 50 gallon for me
i'm a buckies man through and through
shout out to bucky's if you don't know
bucky's it is a uh convenience store i
guess but that's not even doing it
justice no they sell grills everything
deer urine grills
40-odd buck they got everything ammo
whole nine go to the mattresses of
monkeys if you need to
get some get some sesame sticks and some
shrapnel
i know it was so hard to get those folks
out of waco you know what i mean
they're all jacked up on deer corn those
texas people are proud people baby got
enough beef jerky to hold these fence
off for years yeah
gang this is a family episode we are
we're back here at toady's we were on
the road for a little while
down there in texas we had a great time
shout out to houston shout out to austin
shout out to san antone and shout out to
fort worth texas we love you we had a
great time also we'd be yeah texas as
well but then long island was last night
baby
shout out to everybody if you've ever
come out to a live show if you've
supported the pod if you listened once
listen a thousand times whatever we
appreciate all the support you're the
[ __ ] [ __ ] we do it's been amazing so
far we love you we got a few more dates
here coming up for them i'm gonna couple
a big date i'm out strong yeah
um and then we're retired
packing it in for 2022 we'll see in
2023.
he made four grand and walked away
this is all i ever needed
lived in a pace from his mother's house
uh
there you go good stuff i'm a little
scratchy yeah we've had over we've had
over not kovy's that's what you keep
saying which makes me
drink it's always a guy it's not kobe's
it's my allergies yeah okay we'll get
off the ventilator will you i was
playing that ventilation it's a
saxophone
um i was rocking a uh a coldy down in
texas too yeah that was a tough cold
sore yeah
man and just caught me slipping to show
the listener how big of a dirt ball you
are
first day we get down there we get to
see
you immediately made fun of my little
peepee in my intro what are you talking
about i came here for a nice time too
but you threw that out the window and
your shitty hoodie yeah it's nike shout
out to nike i'm getting 50 bucks an
episode to wear this thing
shout out to great people nike
uh what why am i a dirtbag
i mean i know why
what specific reasons
what specific reasons are you about to
name
you choose um
we get that we get down to san antonio
for a nice mexican or mexican lunch
you got the cold sore [ __ ] gleaming
onions
it was hot too that's just when it was
coming in oh yeah
[Laughter]
give me the new stuff no what happens is
you start to feel it and if you don't
get on top of it right away then it's
just it's just gonna do its own thing so
where's that teenager
we're down there in chaos figuring
figuring itself out sexually too
[Laughter]
we're down there in tejas having a nice
lunch
and you're one of the big things that
skeeves me out about i love you
obviously but you know where this is
going one of the big things that skis me
out about is your napkin use it's all
over and you crumble a gentleman will
fall well you know you take one you grad
it's like then it looks like you got a
cold or you jerked off it's just a bunch
of crumpled up napkins on the table
it's like there's no
paper now i don't do that with with
cloth napkins i know if you took me to a
respectable place i would have to use
paper napkins jesus christ this is my
fault now it was a restaurant covered in
pinatas it was it was a mexican place it
was a polish place
[Laughter]
but
i
you got caught slipping i don't know
what to tell you yeah we're sitting i'm
sitting there from now on i want you
across from me i don't know what i want
to be able to i want to be able to see
you at all times okay wild bill cody
never sit with your back to the door so
never sealed my back to a foley i
i place my napkin down i like i
i place my napkin down
and then i eat i'm you know i'm munching
on some queso some salt i'm having a
good time sloppy stuff too i was really
working that napkin
i think i was putting both sides against
the middle with that thing and i looked
down i grabbed my napkin to like dab my
face like a [ __ ] gentleman i'll
[ __ ] have you know
i got the corner going you know doing
that thing
and i've got a herb staring back at you
i go that guy
that's
that's not how i would have placed my
nap like i just know my i know how i
know my modus operandi i know how i
operate and i go i wouldn't that's weird
but i pick it up and against my better
judgment i use it i use the napkin and
i'm like did foley you am i had to go
did foley use i go no you're being
paranoid this is your ocd just relax
have a good time he wouldn't just
randomly use a napkin that's not his and
not realize it
i then look back i put it down i have
another bite of my enchilada my whatever
and i look back over and you grab it and
come up to your face
wipe the snot the herpes the salsa the
queso like a homeless window washer
the whole nine and put it right back
down and i [ __ ] blood dude i [ __ ]
i got the big man coming
i lost it
oh you just boogered dude did you see
that
holy [ __ ] this is why you're gross i
should be put down
you just shot a gummy bear out of your
nose
holy [ __ ] we're getting our own we're
getting separate tables from now on
i want to sneeze guard between me and
you
moving forward
oh yeah well dude i'll tell you and then
you go and then
then
now
you're in fact i'm like i'm now forced
to live in his world right he then goes
i got this my [ __ ] napkin man you're
using my [ __ ] i don't know maybe i
didn't i didn't use it that's yours i'm
like that's my i look over he's got a
mound of crumbled ones on his left and
he's using mine all right because it's
nice i think i'm writing a novel
yeah it's the empty wastebasket
can't get it started so then he goes oh
i got a cold sore come on what the [ __ ]
now then i go
so then we're leaving and we you [ __ ]
juice up you know with the sanitizer on
the way out you know just to [ __ ] and
he goes hey man i would put some of that
on your lip just to kill anything that
got on i'm like really like yeah man i
look over he's rubbing the [ __ ]
sanitizer on his mouth so now i'm forced
to play by his rules i'm doing this you
gotta nape that [ __ ] bro
agent orange that [ __ ] vibration
rolling thunder get that [ __ ] hurt i
mean what a start to the trip
that was a little more hard feelings but
still i'm starting to feel
uh okay i'm starting to become aware
of eating with other people at this
point thanks that i
you decide to check in now that i might
be
a bit of a turn off
put it that way and i think the more we
eat the more comfortable you get like i
think if you went out with
say
you
you know your girlfriend's parents you'd
be very
more reserved i would presume as
somebody you're not trying to impress
it's not even that it's i don't
i don't know what it is
i don't i don't gross i don't i mean you
just had a booger come out of your nose
and we're not sure where it landed may
or may not backpacker maybe it's in
orbit i don't know
[Laughter]
i'm flying around osmosis jones coming
out of my nose oh
listen i i i'm aware of it i'm aware of
the fact that i might be
disgusting to eat in front of you well i
i also think i think you stop you get a
beard now too but you get enchiladas on
i think it's the food you get you know
i'm like a shark you get queso
and then you just go i don't care what i
and you're you get
the breathing pattern changes the speed
you look that you're not making eye
contact the conversation goes to [ __ ]
it's like hannibal
you're the loudest person at a dinner
table who doesn't talk yeah
i see you working the food down your
throat like an anaconda you gotta
you gotta reserve energy and shift gears
two villagers inside of me i got them
open
ate my watch
yes i'm aware i mean it's not even that
it's the it's the every i feel like
everything goes black and you you
know and you're using napkins your spit
you're ejector it's a lot yeah it's a
lot it's a lot
it's a lot from now on i want you and my
[ __ ] 12 o'clock at all times i keep
my [ __ ] eyes on starting at those
long table like rich people
but then the problem is bring a bell if
you're in front of me then i'm [ __ ] i'm
in you know i'm in point-blank [ __ ]
spitting mode yeah i can catch some
[ __ ] shrapnel this way that's no good
either also too
i don't think that i chew with my mouth
open
but you can see in there sometimes
it's not a good all the time i mean
every comment on the youtube is about
your mouth open
tongue's got a mind of its own thing
i'm not hungry but my tongue starving
slides out ah we had a great time though
great [ __ ] trip it was awesome
yeah we had a good time a lot of laughs
every one of my shirts came back ruined
i bought a hundred dollars worth of new
t-shirts i got [ __ ] on it
i don't understand that you've been
wearing that blue palm tree one
in perpetuity but that thing's
[Laughter]
that's like a [ __ ] that's it's like a
new york lawyer right there yeah yeah
nothing sticks to that thing
that's gotten me off a million times
yeah i don't know what it's made of i
don't know either that
the mr clean magic stuff or whatever i
don't know but it ain't going anywhere
i'll tell you that right now i read the
coyote the complaints
it fits me it's comfortable covers my
belly
i okay i don't know where's the why
don't you have more shirts you keep
saying i'm going to get something i do
get them and then i [ __ ] everything
how many are you buying buy 10. i bought
five and i just got stains on every
single one
i'm telling you i'm losing my motor
skills here
i don't know what's going on
uphill battle with the big man jesus
christ
i apologize about the herpes
[Laughter]
you still got a couple days
incubation
i got a slow roller
my guys don't move quick but when they
come they come correct all right
i got a certain blend of herpes i'm
gonna stay on the sun for a couple of
days holy [ __ ] tell you that
one of those pop up on you some
questions i'm pretty i'm pretty good i
don't i don't think i get i think i'm
like immune to them or what like it's
just genetically i don't get them people
in my family have them i don't you know
i don't get them
talk about garbage man
it's a tough luck you know that's when
that's what that's
you have it
you know what i mean you can feel it
yeah because you feel when they come out
you feel like trash
yeah and i never got them until high
school i got somebody bit me on the hand
in a wrestling match and then they
started popping up yeah yeah it's it's
it's a bad could have been out of the
two dollar [ __ ] you were sleeping with
you feared
it was funny in the moment again
[ __ ] hook but you feel them when they
come out they make you like tired now
you're giving me a panic attack let's
stop [ __ ] talking about them i'm
going to give myself i already got the
[ __ ] heebie jeebies in me from you
ah man you're a disgracey odd you are
i am what i am
all right very nice let's get into
some questions family app let's cover
some ground here as you know when you
join a patreon we will answer your
garbage questions yes sir we get
submitted on [ __ ] everywhere emails
dms the whole nine yards this is just
the best way to do it um you know we and
we gotta you know support the crew to
patreons
um so when you join shareholders we'll
answer your the shareholders that's
pretty good of course and also you came
up we should call the listeners the
bozos the bozos that's pretty good right
there you go yeah the bozos i'm not too
shabby sometimes huh i have a couple of
good ideas
i'm i never said you can be gross and
have good ideas sure i can't eat a bowl
of soup in public but still
i get everything on me no matter how
hard i try i get stuff on me i know i i
know i i you know what i think it is i
gotta figure out if anybody knows any
secret stain solutions no let's let me
let's not let's you're you've already
decided to live a life where you're just
gonna get how about we change
some of the eating patterns and stuff
like that nah let's go the other way we
tried that this summer let's let's hit
the gas which by the way we got a
[ __ ]
a fat court weigh-in coming tomorrow
yes 100
i don't care if you have to fast from
now till then to try to [ __ ] juice
the numbers it's [ __ ] happening okay
i'm your problem you're a fat court
parole officer you've been [ __ ]
ducking me you've been missing your
calls your check-ins your [ __ ] piss
test it's happening tomorrow i got a
little glimpse at the pulmonologist
yesterday it ain't good
all right well we'll talk save it save
it for the pot all right that'll be
tomorrow
somebody get me johnny cochran
you better cut a leg off or something
cause you're gonna need it
if the pants don't fit you must have
quit all right let's uh let's get into
let's get into some
kip let's talk about those raycon
everyday earbuds
cause i'm an owner yes got a pair of
course stay charged for a long time yup
sounds fantastic they look cool they fit
in your ears nice they don't slip out
love love my raycons raycons have
improved your life and my life because
you were walking around like a bozo
without without any sort of headphones
nothing now i take calls i could do
things on on right there i can turn my
volume up i can pause the music i can do
this i can do that they're fantastic
yeah you're johnny cool guy all of a
sudden that's right um now you can get
three new sound profiles to make sure
everything you're listening to sounds
it's best just the right amount of bass
uh there's pure mode for podcast
listening balance mode uh for rock heavy
metal bass mode
hit the megabytes i don't even know
about this now you get your hip hop your
edm you big edm kind of guy really so
when the groove hits the groove hips
sure of course i gotta check this out
yeah um they have eight hours of play
time and a 32-hour battery life that's
pretty darn i
feel like it's longer they're
unbelievable they really are uh raycon
started half the price of other premium
auto audio brands but sound just as good
also come with a 45-day happiness
guarantee who else is doing that no
nobody right now uh ru garbage listeners
can get 15 off the raycon order at buy
raycon.com garbage that's by raycon.com
garbage to say 15 on raycon one more
time write it down buy raycon.com
garbage do it do it let's talk about dad
grass baby dadgrass dad grass cbd
absolutely amazing product you ever get
too smoked up back in the day back in
the day that's why i stopped that's why
i stopped hitting the cheap you're all
paranoid paranoid think the feds are
closing in don't need it anymore you can
clear your head you can relax with dad
grass cbd and not worry about the stress
and the paranoia nothing but enjoyment
baby oh baby best part about it that
grass is legal organic smokable hemp
relax you wind you down nice easy peasy
um all dag grass products are federally
legal for ages 21 and over and ships
right to your door anywhere in the u.s
look at that whether you're looking for
a new buzz or a chill way to enjoy an
old favorite pal oh walk down memory
lane dad grass will leave you in a
euphoric mood get the credence out
go to the garage maybe hit a stix
concert work on the camaro do some some
bench presses or something like that
like a twister i was born to walk alone
doobies without the goobies all right i
like it grass right now dadgrass is
offering our listeners 20 off your first
order when you go to dadgrass.com
garbage go to dadgrass.com garbage for
20 off your first order one more time
write it down dadgrass.com
garbage now back to the show
uh let's get into some questions
business my eating habits well this is a
hard feeling we got to do a hard
feelings after this too this is more
hard feelings is more of a your gross
kind of podcast
um all right let's get into some
questions here this one i've honestly
never thought of this is from a guy
named king
do you pronounce it 20 or
20. i'm a 20. i'm with a ch 20
20 20 it's 20 bucks yeah what's what's
the opposite it would be 20 20 with a t
tw 20 20 20 20.
i don't hear the difference
how do you how would you say it t1 i
would say 20. 20 20. give me 20 bucks
20. that's a tw i say i say 20.
like ch 20 20 20 20 20. that's what i
said give me 20. it's 20 bucks let me
get 20 on pump 2. 20. i do did i do i
never thought about it that sounds like
a guy who runs a card game
going over to 20. he's going over maybe
you do have herpes
c-h-w-e-n-t-y 20 no 20. 20 bucks give me
20 on two
i the way i see it in my head is
she there's it's like u-n-e-y 20.
sounds like something a weird subway
would make
20. let me get a 6-inch 20.
we get a 20-inch 20.
call it a [ __ ] day
um
yeah that's trash 20 if you're saying 20
it's trash if you're saying with ch
right yeah all right
so you admit you're garbage
yeah i get a career based on what do you
think
although nike's not garbage check it out
nike.com
for all your that's got marshalls
written all over it no there was only
one of those in the store no i got this
at uh football i went to marshalls the
other that places
when i went there to get something what
are you doing in there socks
that shows why i went to the gap got
some new socks and it's right next to
socks at like the [ __ ] drugstore now
pick him up at cvs yeah i don't i mean i
was right next to a [ __ ]
marshalls you live near marshalls
there's a marshalls and a gap factory
outlet that is
what does that mean they make it there
what's going on
right off the press
it's coming on a conveyor belt
i jump in them
um
all right did you ever all right this is
from tim uh tim monroe did you do you or
did you ever own anything with a fake
autograph on it
uh baseball glove
who signed it
herbie hancock who was it
john mayer
that's all i had on me
who signed it or who fake science bruce
sutter
of the sutter home family
shout out to niece it's just engraved in
there like when they sell it to you
oh that's not a fake okay what do you
mean fake i guess if you had like you
know you got like a [ __ ] bon jovi
head shot and it was not something you
just signed yourself not you but i
assumed you know you bought it in fact
realized it wasn't real or something
any sort of fake autograph were you an
autographed family get the [ __ ] out of
here we weren't we weren't even a big
memorabilia family we have our claim to
fame is that
all-star baseball that's signed by like
terry mulholland or somebody
jim frank conan and terry mulholland i
got that like it was like the 92
all-star game the only time that we ever
autographed seeked was uh we were in
philadelphia airport going somewhere and
michael spinks remember michael springs
he was a heavyweight boxer yeah
was was eating in the food court next to
us are you gonna finish your macaroni
salad
i got four hungry kids over here
and my mom recognized him and went up
ask him
out but he got tuned up like two days
later yeah he was gearing up for a big
fight he got laid the [ __ ] out that was
it for the autographs
maybe the fanatic
the philly fanatic can't sign an
autograph
was gonna hold the pen i don't know i
thought he did i told the story before
we jumped on our car one time
you j he jumped on your car yeah we were
driving through public square in
wilkes-barre it was like a a festival it
sounds more like you hit him
sounds a little more like patty patty
had a couple of spritzers in here drove
on to a t-ball game and took out the
fanatic hey listen they can't keep your
mouth shut all right
if you know what's going to want to play
this town again
no why were you an autographed kid
shaking no i just said that was the only
thing we had and it was like we would
get [ __ ] uh
when my my dad owned a company there was
always like it was always like goth out
and like [ __ ] like that like where they
would like auction something he was
always like
getting stuff that like nobody he'd be
like do you want and he'd be like i got
this and things are pretty trashy well
it always for like a benefit it was
always
it was always like some like you know
plumber's kid died and it was like the
foundation or whatever and he would go
and donate money or whatever like do the
you know here you know the 50 50 raffle
here's 100 bucks you know whatever and
he would always get like they would get
people to donate [ __ ] like oh here's a
donated [ __ ] mike schmidt
hoagie santa did i ever tell you mike
schmidt used to have a hoagie shop in my
hometown
i ever tell you that that just came
roaring back to me my dad despises him
the schmidt oh why because he's saying
your mom
him in the fanatic
i'm sorry [ __ ] dirt i'm sorry patty
no because he stinks in the booth
he does he doesn't
he stinks on the announcements okay so
he hates him now back in the day he was
a player no i was young i just remember
going there and getting [ __ ] cheese
fries that [ __ ] mike schmidt's hoagie
shop was he what was he working there no
he wasn't behind the [ __ ] grill idiot
it was in our strip mall in uh richboro
pennsylvania that was the only one
because i'd never i think there was two
i had another okay probably in like
langhorne or levittown or something
talking about blowing your cage
yeah
like
you're gonna make millions of dollars
off [ __ ] hoagies you idiot mike
schmidt going toe-to-toe
no he got something yeah think again
pretty boy
[Laughter]
yeah i remember going in there though
getting a mean [ __ ]
mean set of fries
i would i was too i didn't eat hoagies
back then i still don't really dabble
[Laughter]
unless it's
you weren't riding the lightning yet
i wasn't eating hoagies
i've been eating hoagies since i can
remember
yeah you've been smelling like
get them in the crib
dude the first result for mike schmidt's
hoagies on google is an article from
1995.
probably closing or something dude two
eggs any style serving home fries bacon
and toast 199. what are we doing
[Laughter]
the foul ball special yeah
you just got your four the ball why
don't you walk down to mike schmitz
and get yourself some hash browns
[Laughter]
try the dugout fries
batter up on these beer battered french
fries
oh man shout out to the schmidt family
man he's still cooking you think i mean
he's still alive what do you mean is
mike schmidt alive i just told you he's
in the booth oh is he yeah he he's he's
an announcer for nbc sports philly okay
with tom mccarthy
john crock shout out to the crooksters
one not croc i was
prime age john kruck lost a testicle no
i had no idea about that
i i don't know if we ever talked about
this
it was the cat he was the catcher right
it was the catcher for the phillies
throughout the 90s no he was the first
base first baseman uh for the catcher
throughout the night for the phillies
throughout the 90s and
i must have been about eight when it
made
[ __ ] public news that he lost a
testicle he had to get one removed are
you toby give me a goo gun that cause i
don't know if that's even true one nut
cruck
because there was also a story in philly
about jerry pencoli that he had a gerbil
up his ass that was richard geary idiot
what was the dude's full name uh john
crock it should be k-r-u-c-k
you don't know who john cruck is
he was homeschooled what do you want
from playing kickball by himself
hey i got a home run and threw my shelf
out at first
john crock one testicle he's got it
yeah yeah yep
was it cancer no water skiing accident
[Laughter]
catfish jumped up yanked her out it was
a sack
yeah also i wasn't a big phillies guy in
1992. my bad
it's a golden year for him
shout out to the phils so 92 yeah i was
like six or seven when that and that as
a joke some public figure losing a
testicle
that made for a lot of laughs on the
playground well around the same time
jerry pencoli do you know jerry pinecole
is no he's kind of like an entertainment
uh you know anchor reporter you know
journalist or whatever you want to call
it but he started out in philly
and he was the philly he was one of the
philly anchors and this rumor went
around that he had a gerbil up his butt
that what happened to everybody though
why was why were the 90s like that that
was richard gere had that
dude the the john crock thing goes way
deeper
big testicles all over this thing
i don't know he was hit in the balls by
a teammate and then went to get a check
by the doctor and that's when they found
the cancer whoa
that's a goocher look at that thank god
that's [ __ ] cool
shout out to the croc
um
all right let's see here
um this one's just funny this is from
toady's goodies has anyone in your
family renewed their vows
[Laughter]
packing up these goodies but that might
be some merch coming soon
that's pretty [ __ ] good oh we started
doing like edible arrangements tony's
goodies goodies goodies
has anyone in your family renewed their
vows
to me that's tv [ __ ] that's like sitcom
[ __ ] or movie [ __ ] or you cheated
is that what that is that's what's never
[ __ ] what come on
i don't know i've never done it you have
to redo your license it's not because
you're doing people on my family cheat
they get divorced it's easy
i don't know that's weird yeah i
wouldn't i don't think i would attend if
one of my
cousins or someone was like hey we're
renewing our vows i'm like i see it the
reception and you ain't getting a gift
yeah they get the [ __ ] out of here kick
rocks with that it better be if it's
cash bar you're definitely not chocolate
fountain better be flowing when i get
there
that's whack i never understood that
yeah i don't get it i don't get it
either toby you give me an experience
anything like that why would you ask him
a question when you know he's not on the
mic i didn't realize that uh nah no one
in my family's ever done that [ __ ] no
that's whack
yeah renewing your vows that's always
like in the backyard i i guess if you
wanted to do it for yourself you know
what i mean like say like but why
what's the point i just think it's like
you know it's it's like you know uh but
why do you gotta drag other people too
no that's no that's what i'm saying
don't take her on a trip yeah don't get
the [ __ ] cruise oh yeah i have a
threesome i don't [ __ ] know that's
what i'm saying involved me on a
saturday if you want to do it for your
own like hey let's just you know kind of
check back in after 25 years and do this
nice thing whatever just for yourselves
for sure [ __ ] keep me out of it don't
invite me lose my address yeah i'm not
[ __ ] going yeah watch you stand under
us you know some [ __ ]
some like gazebo and [ __ ] talk to
some [ __ ] that you've been banging for
25 years sorry i don't know what that's
crude painting of love
i would assume there's some kind of
etiquette with that like i don't think
there's no way presents are that's a
[ __ ] cass grab if if if you're
expecting presents no there's no way i
mean also but if you're hemmed up and
you need an influx of cash not a bad
dirt not a bad dirtbag move i changed my
stance on this renew your valve if you
need it renew your vowels juice up a
little bit yeah and also a lot of people
throw yourself down the stairs like a
gentleman you gotta go fund me going
also too man about it i do think there's
a lot and you know myself included
there's a lot of people out there
looking for excuses to party so if it's
like people are like hey we're go you
know we can go here get all banged up
that's an anniversary party yeah we're
having a big anniversary party
i wouldn't want to go to your
anniversary party really oh i've been to
some [ __ ] bangers i don't think so oh
yeah so when you were a kid two things i
looked forward to you were going to pay
like you were going to adults
anniversary parties yeah as a kid yeah
that seems like swinger [ __ ] to me i
don't that doesn't make sense
anniversary i've never heard of anybody
having an anniversary party i might have
played around a little bit
no the things i remember holidays
obviously but all of my aunts uncles mom
and dad's 40th birthday parties that's a
little different they all turned 40. i
remember that the [ __ ] party trees
were flowing i knew something was up
because i didn't get invited to my mom's
it was an adult affair oh man yeah i was
with i was with my dad on that one yikes
yeah
didn't get invited yeah wow i know kids
went that was the problem with our our
our family's so big and we've like i
talked about this like there's you have
to draw hard lines in the sand based on
the venue and like what you want the
thing to be and if it's like if you're
inviting yeah they don't want your
[ __ ] big head there gumming up to
work trying to get loose exactly well
it's like well if you're gonna bring the
kids
they still do it now like hey it's just
like cousins only or it's like just just
parent like it's just the ants and uncle
tears are going and like that's just all
you know that's what it was and i guess
they probably want to party without some
[ __ ] kids you know do some poppers
and stuff there was always like risque
cards
being thrown around at those things
you know what i mean like you'd open the
car like a huge dick would come out oh
yeah or something
[Laughter]
where would you get one of these cars
you know all the balloons were black
like over the hill and stuff yeah i
didn't know what the [ __ ] there was
always like some sexual innuendo jokes
going like hey weren't you the guy who
you know or whatever you know type thing
yeah
those sexy cards you get at spencer's
gifts have you ever been to a family
party where a stripper or
what air dancers
no i i went to some dirt bags something
i was like i don't even know who we were
i don't know i don't know this guy
i think it was like a wedding or
something was that a [ __ ] vfw
or a roller skating pal i forget where
it was you're getting married
shout out to the skating palace on the
bully just kill each other now
i can't tell if you can't remember
you're just trying to cover your tracks
no i can't remember i genuinely can't
remember i remember a dancer
i remember a male i remember a male
dancer
i swear to god
i remember a male dancer at was one of
my aunts you never forget your first
true love
wait a male dancer shout out to randy
the cop
that's guilty that's where my love of
law enforcement started
son of a [ __ ] never fixed the cable
yeah i don't know why
a male dancer at a family party this was
the 80s man it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter
it was at uh because we we lived in town
line at the time
i don't think it was at the mayor's
house
we lived in town which was a rental
community and they had a pretty tight
clubhouse by the pool you know the
there's two stripper poles in there
but i remember they had a party and a
dancer came he didn't strip or anything
it was his day off but
i definitely remember like a cousin or
somebody sitting down and him dancing
for her
and like he had the radio and everything
yeah why the [ __ ] was i there
i don't know let's get this party
started anybody got any d batteries
he's gonna be going around with the tip
bucket
yeah why the [ __ ] was i there
it looks like we got some law breakers
on our hands tonight
get better help on the phone man
yikes i remember one two i remember you
remember those like dance floors at like
a vfw or what like those halls
low drop ceilings and like the circle
table and then that dance floor was just
in the middle of nowhere there was you
know it was all of a sudden just
hardwood yeah
and [ __ ] horwood
[Applause]
those things are trash there was a girl
that's why they had to stop doing that
[ __ ] cause people were slipping and
breaking their ankle i guess it had to
be a wedding it's like a bowling lane
yeah
and
i remember that i don't know the bride
or the guy but he was rooting around the
dress looking for the garter or whatever
oh that is [ __ ] and i remember being
there like eight years old being like
dude you're gonna let this dude do this
to your girl what the [ __ ] he just got
married she's already [ __ ] setting
the goods out
i never i still don't get that as an
adult i don't understand that no i think
they stay kind of they're they're
starting to get away from that [ __ ] they
don't really do that my circles there
yeah they wouldn't i mean if
say me and my wife had a big wedding
it's the best man and my best man got
under her dress in front of my my fat my
uncle what the [ __ ] like somebody be
tuned up real quick we're getting too
[ __ ] like that's crazy talk what is
the best man takes takes [ __ ] the bride
[Laughter]
um
what is that toby what is it he takes
the garter it's the best man i believe
it's the best he goes in there takes it
doesn't he throw it to the rest of the
dirtbags because i always remember my
older cousins
um
shout out to the duck shout out to flo
their their squad getting married and
they were they high school mascots
they would they would hang them
they would hang the garter in their car
dude i was just gonna say i remember
being in one of my stepdad's friend's
cars like pickup trucks and he had a
black one with white lace hanging i'm
being like i'm gonna throw up i thought
it was panties or something i didn't
know what it was
jumping up a little bit yeah those
things are real [ __ ] sleazy i don't
know what's going on at your weddings
but the garter is supposed to be removed
by the groom
oh well we party down there in the
delaware valley
we play ball a little differently in
wilkesboro pennsylvania i'm taking that
yeah they would hang them from the
mirrors yeah and you would keep it
see i just smelled the pickup truck i
was in
[ __ ] winston's and [ __ ] tend up
pennzoil oh you know dudes back in the
day were in there
[ __ ] diddling around real quick
before they got a hold of that thing
those mechanic fingers
go underneath like an old camera yeah
sniffing around
oh god that's trash
renew your vows yeah it's a tough one
man
all right this is a home this is from
dakota brown no any card tricks
[Laughter]
yeah if you're pulling the seven of
spades out of someone's [ __ ] i know
one magic trick
that's actually pretty good how to make
a hoagie disappear
come on people
if i don't say them who will
yeah i could do it for you but i'd have
to write something down
i don't know how that would play on on
camera for time i know a pretty d i know
a couple pretty decent card tricks
parlor tricks if you will are you gonna
do it i'm gonna do it keep talking okay
yeah i know a couple couple ones
little razzle dat and like there's one
where you think you're like oh i know
and then you're like i don't know how
you did that last [ __ ] part
i did magic tricks oh my god at a camp
talent show and it was like the first
trick you learned out of the book
zero applause
[Laughter]
hey nerd why don't you make yourself
disappear
bunk c was not impressed
here my next trick are they going to
leave
i'll do even worse i did the devil
sticks at a at a school as i forgot
about this devil stinks yeah i did the
devil i did a devil all those yeah
[Laughter]
a school or like camp uh talent show
[Laughter]
you fat little bastard
oh my god yeah
oh yeah
uh-huh
that's loser [ __ ] yeah
i was pretty decent at them i remember
but hold on i didn't account for the
light show that they were gonna do
my eyes
set yourself on fire
dude they hit they hit that shrubland i
don't know what the [ __ ]
ah goddammit this fat kid just [ __ ]
himself i had a seizure i lost it up in
the strobe light it came down and hit me
in the head the first big trick
[Laughter]
what a [ __ ]
have you ever launched it on like a
school production or anything like that
he does it on here all the time
i had a set fall apart and during his
school play oh my god union job was
you go itsy baby
oh man i'll never forget the panic of
looking up in those strobe lights and
the devil the mid the stick being up
there and just seeing it like you
know [ __ ] pump fake its way down to
me being like no way i got this
his father left soon after it was very
it was very lackluster
man
i had the music
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
while you're picking it up and trying to
get it back going oh jesus did you
recover
no i still haven't that's why i do
change schools what are you talking
about
his real name is a halligan i didn't try
it with chainsaws that year
thank god we couldn't get the insurance
you get me a set i'm going to buy
instead of devil and we'll put it on the
patreon i'm pretty good i remember this
lady that babysat us oh toby's better oh
god
i remember this lady baby status uh when
we were kids and her boyfriend showed up
and started doing that [ __ ] on the front
lawn i was like you take that comedy
[ __ ] next door bro these colors don't
run my dad's gonna let me kick this [ __ ]
out of here plus i'm gonna tell him you
touch this get out of here with that
yeah all right here's my here's my trick
okay
now
i want you to think of a number between
one and a hundred okay sure you have it
yeah okay
now
i'm gonna put it on this piece of paper
okay right here and i'm gonna hand it to
you don't open it i'm not gonna open it
okay number between one and a hundred
tell me what it is
go
37.
37.
are you sure it wasn't 40.
yeah this is you hammond this is the
hollywood behind it oh my god let me see
if i can tap into the spirits hey fatty
shut it up and let me open this piece of
paper
yeah okay
you said 37 i said 40. sure
nah i [ __ ] it up
you have to do the math hey let's meet
in the middle or something probably
right dude
hey what are you [ __ ] johnny two
times trying to [ __ ] blow me up i'm
working here [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] christ
well if the joke depends on you doing
math i think we're [ __ ] i'm the mass
magician open it up what does it say i
said you said 37 i said 40. call the
proctologist
i got a rabbit stuck up my ass
what's it say i'll be off by three
pretty good huh sure
i was off by three yeah
you get it
sure yeah yeah i don't know how you did
it
well
good magician never doubts
you're stunned right now you don't know
what to do not really i mean i'm in your
head i'm just trying to remember you
said 40 after he said 37.
it doesn't matter he did no i didn't
yeah you said pick a number between one
i said 37 you go okay i'll say 40. yeah
oh my gosh so i just always i'm just
whatever you say i said i say three more
three less and i write down on the piece
of paper i'll be off by three yeah yeah
yeah yeah we got it
there you go kids i mean i didn't really
think you were [ __ ]
you know i didn't think this was a ouija
board all right ready look inside your
underwear
they've been wet today i gotta be honest
yeah a little pit's going to underneath
the thing sure can i take a peek
oh my god
i like how you thought that was going to
get a laugh so you hammed it up even oh
my god you're sweating and probably have
poop in your underwear as we speak
and you know it
it's like it's like it's like psychology
101 like oh my god look how fat this guy
is you're rude of my next trick
watch me fill my underwear with a dump
for my next trick i was [ __ ] my
pants
that's terrible
[Music]
no i don't know any magic tricks other
than that one which is great you guys
can use it
matt richards actually taught me that it
took me about three weeks to figure it
out oh three yeah it's pretty good
i don't know if that's against the
magician's code what i just did there my
life could be in danger
[Laughter]
i think the heart disease is
the biggest thing we need to worry about
not a bunch of virgins coming after you
um all right let's see here let's uh
this one we've talked about but this is
kelly this is the first question
uh have you ever taken the bottle of
wine you brought to a party home with
you because you've never opened it
that's a [ __ ] no-no that's a gift to
the host that's a gift to the house it's
crazy yeah that's it's [ __ ]
cuckoo bananas it's crazy
that's not all kind of garbage around
here yeah even if you don't drink show
up with something show up yeah show up
show up with chocolates flowers a dildo
whatever i don't care you know
but yeah you can't be never take it back
it's a gift to them unless
no there is no one less because there's
there's been people who've said that
kelly keegs i believe is guilty of this
she'll take the bottle of wine home with
her yeah that's no bueno yeah no good
yeah yeah yeah
you leave it
stays there yeah uh now i have
encountered the flip side of that
where you bring a nice bottle of wine
where you intend it for the party
but the host sees that it's a nice
bottle of wine hides it off and [ __ ]
puts it away for later sure that's a
dirtbag move yes yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah for sure
yeah for sure for sure you can't be
doing that it's for the party it's for
that night it lives and dies at night
um all right this is from dion sandals
home run of a name uh a long time patron
never had a question read
ever put a stereo or boom box in the
backseat of your car to play music
because the radio doesn't work
i've done this in the tigo i would do
this with a bluetooth speaker with a
bose bluetooth i would put it on the
dashboard
within the past year i've done there
probably you know
put it on the dashboard
[ __ ] cooking off that thing and i
remember this we were at a stoplight and
a guy looked over and saw it it was just
like it was a level of shame
that just ran through my body it's a
little more prevalent now because they
got the earbuds but i used to see people
driving around with their headphones on
yeah which i thought was illegal it has
to be yeah it has to be it can't be i
can't beat it you got those discman
[ __ ] headphones on the ones that like
stick out and go in your ears
that's man remember the wrap around
headphones when they dropped remember
when it was here and then it went behind
the head yeah they were like the sony
walk or video or vo or whatever those
things dropped the kids would walk in
when they were like red or blue i just
had those [ __ ] ones with the foam on
them the one didn't work those ones with
the foam good luck getting them in there
oh yeah they would always fall out that
[ __ ] stunk i had one of the first
walkmans
because for some reason my mom worked at
the gap they were giving them away
and we had them it was just a radio
mm-hmm pretty cool though yeah i
remember my buddy had one and then i the
only disc man i proper own those yellow
disc men when they hit the walkman no
i'm talking about the disc man yeah
those things were like that was that was
money that was rich people that was
money yeah yeah you got to work at
merrill lynch or something like that to
get those i never and like there was
such a disconnect between technology and
my parents that if i was like hey i want
a new bike or something you know what i
mean they'd be like okay like we they
get that but like or like hey you know i
needed i need a new hockey or something
or a baseball bat they understood that
but like to go to that because that was
when technology started cooking yeah to
be like i want a disc man they would be
like what the [ __ ] so the only one i
want to a raffle in like sixth grade at
like
the [ __ ] something and it came with a
disc man not a disc man like a generic
cd player disc man the raffle yeah it
was like for like school or something it
was like something i don't know guess
the jelly beans yeah it was it was
probably something along those i won
something at school i don't know if i i
don't remember what it was
i mean like it came with that and it was
green and it was like it just didn't
sucked
and if that was when everybody was
cooking with the skip proof the [ __ ]
you know the five second delay or
whatever
dude i and i had to like i had to walk
with mine like like it was a [ __ ]
full thing full full champagne flute
just [ __ ] walking with it so it
wouldn't [ __ ] bounce yeah you
couldn't listen to it in the car go over
a speed bump you got all hemmed up
bam
to the parents out there either get them
either get them the right thing or don't
get them at all it's a worse it damages
the psychology of the child if you get
them the [ __ ] knock off the knockoff
yeah just go like oh yeah do you have an
ipad no it's worse to be like i have a
you know a b pad or whatever they're
like get the [ __ ] out of here with this
thing because i remember i i wanted a
skateboard one year and i got a um a
nash we've talked about this a handful
of times yeah yeah yeah still think
about it i told you i went to the whole
life could have been different i went to
the skate shop they left to get new
trucks
yeah
it's off look it's a it's it's a level
of confidence
sucks you out it sucks your whole life
yeah yeah yeah
bam it's true though
uh also one we've touched on uh but new
patreon never had a question read did
your parents ever bring their own nips
on a flight to make their own cocktails
versus buying the flight attendants
never
parents in booze like that
now they'd bring a bottle of fluid down
to shores neither did mine uh my stepdad
recently they went on a cruise like a
couple of years ago
and like he had like
an elaborate bladder system and like
hanging up in his tux or whatever shut
the [ __ ] up yeah like jesus he gets to
get booze on one he likes the booze wait
i thought all that [ __ ] was free on
cruises not booze i don't think the food
is but i don't think the booze that's
where they get you because you can only
buy the booze there do you really want
to save a couple hundred bucks for that
i don't get that [ __ ] yeah i used to
have a buddy that used to do that i
think we talked about it he would he
would he would bring a backpack to bars
where they got wise to it and he'd have
like a [ __ ] handle of captain morgan
in there yeah i never did that no
there may or may not be an older
gentleman in my family who had the
flip-flops that you could put booze in
that would bring them to baseball games
wow
the flip what was it like like the reefs
yeah and like you could fill up the
bottom of the reef oh with booze
it was like the the the flip-flop itself
was a container that is correct
what the [ __ ] how bad were you at little
league
[ __ ] jesus christ
yeah flask sandals they're called
get the [ __ ] out of here yeah
that's [ __ ] bad news
none of that [ __ ] yeah
that's [ __ ] so gross yeah well
whatever little bird [ __ ] chaser what
stuff sterile you know what i mean it'll
[ __ ] sanitize anything
um
all right let's see
uh this is from haywood ever put water
in condiments ranch ketchup because
there wasn't enough to squeeze out and
you still want to get your money's worth
to make it stretch that ruins the
condiment for me ruins it i've done it
but i use milk
but like what like i would you would
think like a couple of draw like it
can't be water water you put watery
ketchup on something ruins the [ __ ]
omelette not ketchup but i i made uh
blue cheese dressing and ranch dressing
disappeared
uh stretch a little further with a
little bit of whole milk yeah shake it
up a little bit that's not for maybe a
little salt little pepper a little olive
oil
just kind of do your thing that's not
for me
i can't i can't i can't get away with
that um
let's see okay that was haywood uh this
one from jt never had a question right
any friends or family currently saving
money for new teeth
it's bad when you gotta when you get a
tooth fund
that's a tough one really is i get it
you're trying to better you're talking
about implants just says new teeth i
don't know it says new teeth we got
molars on layaway
i had a couple incisors i did have a
couple of friends parents who didn't do
well and then started doing well and got
the adult braces
yeah that's man trying to listen to
somebody's dad yelling you with [ __ ]
rubber bands in his mouth
[ __ ] you
holy [ __ ] where were we he was a guy
working somewhere
it was a girl
no it was a kid
and he had the front braces
he scared the [ __ ] out of me every time
he opened him he was like our point man
somewhere to be like hey there's our
waiter or something no it was a it was a
waitress we had at uh twin peaks in in
texas she had braces on no but there was
a kid somewhere that i was just i think
he was like a waiter or a bartender and
every time i forgot because i was
boozing
and he rhymes oh [ __ ]
it looked like a he looked like a bond
villain or something
[Laughter]
yeah it was a [ __ ] tough one
i mean but i i i respect that you're
better in yourself harder especially
after the front teeth and your heart hey
i want to get my [ __ ] act together
sure you know what i mean
invisalign though
well that's different than new teeth new
teeth indicates like rotted or missing
or not there
that that you know or like
real [ __ ] jacked or where you're
gonna get the veneers
yeah
um all right this one's from kyle and i
forgot about these have you ever rented
or owned a jerry springer jerry springer
xxx tape or dvd do you remember those no
that's a dip so jerry springer had a set
of dvds you see the boobies when they
ripped each other yeah it was like the
real [ __ ] sexy stuff like the the too
hot for tv type stuff no but i got
caught up in a couple of knockers
hanging off i got caught up in a couple
of girls one gone wild videos
man those things dude that [ __ ]
infomercial would do it for me
there was a there was a blonde girl in
[ __ ] arizona who had my number
[Laughter]
big set of cans on her
yeah man that was
those things were scandalous
did you ever watch them i'm telling you
yeah
what are you gonna do here
put myself in jail
i'm admitting it
yeah there's some lake down in texas i
don't know like in [ __ ] lake or
something i don't know what it was but
these kids were [ __ ] partying all the
boats go out and they that's in i don't
know i think that's in arizona like like
havasu and stuff like that i don't know
i don't know i don't know i don't know
where it was but we're going oh good
lord yeah those you know god bless that
was also that guy got the [ __ ] i don't
know if you ever heard that guy got the
what was coming to him a lot of that was
like they didn't know or they were drunk
or they can you know they didn't really
realize that it was going to go
nationwide really it was it was a [ __ ]
it was dicey and then a dad
i could have this story wrong but a dad
whose daughter got like exploited on it
and like lost her job or kicked out of
college something happened he went and
[ __ ] like tuned them up
but like even we might have even talked
about this he like tied him down and
sodomized him and [ __ ] it was like yeah
we did not talk about it he really went
after it i'm pretty sure because they
made a law and order about it
i have to make a long order about it
what was that dude's name
wasn't he he was t-bones gonna have it
joe francis ah three million dollars he
had to pay
joe francis yeah is the guy the owner of
it right wasn't he like a personality
for a little while i believe so he was
in the videos and stuff
like hey what's up i'm joe i didn't know
any of that
yeah sure enough i never saw it
i'm telling you man
um and then didn't he get like his home
got broken into and he got all jammed up
no pun intended
yeah yeah something like that he went to
jail
yeah damn
i don't know all the d.o let's not get
into all the gory details but uh that
guy got jammed up rightfully so i
believe if my recollection of the story
that's right that's what you get
punk
yeah but i never owned any of those
i don't know i bought them can you come
across those yeah somebody's dad got a
couple in them [ __ ] got caught
slipping yeah he took the heat for it
when it showed up and the wife yelled at
him and somehow ended up in the basement
sure
and the scavengers came over yeah um
clean
all right this one's from bryce uh have
you or anyone in your family ever put
your own hair on a plate at a restaurant
to get discount slash meal for free
no no that's i mean
that's crazy i feel like i would be the
one that got caught doing that yeah then
you're that guy
damn i can ban from mickey d's i ever
saw my dad do that oh that was yeah we
were never like
we were never even like get some we're
not a complaining family we're [ __ ]
head down keep your [ __ ] mouth shut
if you don't like it it's gonna you know
we'll then about it on the ride home but
i can tell you about the two the only
two times in the history my 45 years
with the foley family great organization
they've had their problems
only twice has my family complained in a
restaurant and once is that my father
took a big swig of sour milk at a at a
uh
cracker barrel
two
my brother almost swallowed an
industrial staple in a place called
hungry pilgrim and an apple cobbler
that we took for a ride
[Laughter]
all the free desserts you can have
um
i swear to god they're the only two
times we have now we'll [ __ ] trash
the place in the car yeah of course
all right of course but no never yeah
can't do it the only time the confidence
no
we're not confident people
um the only time shut up you lead at
home my mom
would get a little
the sullivans are a [ __ ] kooky bunch
they can fly off the handle from time to
time and
she would
lose it from time to time not in a bit
never in like a in a just way i remember
the one time we were flying [ __ ] east
wind airlines now defunct east wind
i remember we were waiting
this [ __ ] plane pulls up it's got a
bumblebee on it and my brother's like i
ain't getting on this [ __ ] plane like
no [ __ ] way
this is his tail spin so we have to we
have to do an emergency landing
not because of the gear or anything they
were running out of gas
something had there was a f i forgot we
landed in georgia we're going to florida
we landed in georgia
and this guy started complaining
rightfully so cause like we stopped and
they're like oh we need to check
something and then they let other
passengers on who got stranded it was
like real [ __ ]
it was a low budget airline trying to
make it work and it you know because
like their other pool airline it was
yeah it was an uber so it was like a
tough look and then this guy started
screaming he was like yeah what the [ __ ]
is going on here you [ __ ] like
let's [ __ ] people freak out on
airplanes it's stressful you know you
know you're [ __ ] tense what if you
don't like flying you're tense and then
you're like dude we were over florida
and we turned back around to go to
georgia like this guy could be like
i don't know he could just be going to
get [ __ ] high and drunk with his
buddies or he could be going to a
business meeting he could be going to
[ __ ] he could be missing a wedding he
could be you know his kid could be being
born something like an adult i mean i
understand if they leave in a tarmac for
like five hours and it's [ __ ] 100
degrees or whatever
i yeah i i whatever i don't know he's
he's he starts [ __ ]
shooting off at the mouth
then the
flight attendants get involved then the
cops come on like the local georgia
police that's when the lip dries up and
he nah he's going it's a real he's got
you [ __ ] [ __ ] and then like
he had gotten into with another
passenger and they started like gripping
the other passenger up to like get him
out of there and they were leaving the
problem guy oh and denise did not like
that what he's doing here's him he's the
one we're easy easy nice easy does it
i'm not [ __ ] getting you out of hawk
in [ __ ] greensboro alabama
working the chain gang for the weekend
trying to go to disney get my [ __ ]
epcot on
yeah they'll get a little
hairy um
oh that was the food food restaurant for
free trash
let's do one of tomorrow and we got a
buggy we got a bug
this one i don't even understand but i
got a lot of likes on patreon ever this
is from jake ever scratch an itch with
your teeth
i guess that's yeah the [ __ ]
oh
it makes sense yes i have
[Music]
yeah i'll go to any length to satisfy an
itch
a fork
a hanger the remote
yeah do it in hotel
what do you do with that hotel remote
you take it out of the sleeve you take
it out of the protective sleeve or you
leave it in there dude that thing's that
thing's got fecal matter on it for sure
i used uh
one of the hotels i had i had an itch
and i couldn't reach it and that was
like the middle of the night and i
grabbed the thing and it was right
on the side of my my left thigh in the
back near the butt cheek and scratched
it with that
it works in a pinch toby can we cut that
jesus christ
that's why you get these little roku
remotes and i'll do [ __ ]
i need a
all right let's see here
let's do two more and this is from
joshua
i'm not even sure i understand this but
he's been asking it for a little while
ever bummed a bernie off a homeless guy
i don't that would never even cross my
mind you're hemmed up
if you're borrowing something from a
homeless guy
maybe he might not be talking home he
might be talking more like a street guy
which is a little different
but i'm thinking like patterned rags
like shopping cart posted up on
like under an overhang or something
those guys never have smokes on that's
what i'm saying they're always asking me
for burning where's this guy living with
a homeless guy's got burned i know you
must you have to be a nice part of town
you're not in a great spot if you're
bumming anything off off a homeless guy
um all right then we'll get out of here
on this one
um this was from al and we've talked
about this briefly
but when making a pb and j to use
separate utensils for the pb and the j
or the same like everybody knows i'm a
peanut butter man through and through i
don't do to jay strictly pb
but if i go over your house and there's
jelly in the [ __ ] peanut butter
i'm upset about that yeah i'm upset i'm
really upset it just goes to show that
you're
it's not sanitary to me as a child i
believe my mother's move was
knife butter knife for the peanut butter
spoon teaspoon for the jelly yeah she
would spread the jelly at the back of
the
learn this trick
two pieces of bread
you [ __ ]
peanut butter up to one put it down then
you take the the
plain one that you're gonna put the
jelly on and you clean the knife sure
give it a couple of those
then scoop your jelly out spread it on
there close your sandwich get your chips
your glass of milk your pickles sit down
put on the a team and enjoy yourself
yeah
that's out of lazy though you should do
a spoon though be a gentleman think so
yeah you're doing that out of laziness
you could also use a rag but you're
using i do most things out of laziness
which has led to some great innovations
like use my napkins
well this was lovely yeah had a nice
time with you yeah it was great i feel
like you're breaking up with us
well listen we kind of you know i just
don't see it anymore
gang we [ __ ] love you woo yeah we do
do yourself a favor do us a favor if
you're in the uh philadelphia area
october 27th grab some tickets helium
comedy club it is going to sell out it's
going to sell out for sure also new york
city date being announced new york city
date being announced i didn't even know
we were allowed to see that
we might not be able to
but the agents haven't listened this far
into this episode for sure
[Laughter]
gang we're ending the year with a bang
we love you thank you for everything
thank you for the love for supporting us
thank you everybody that came to the
moon tower comedy festival all the long
island amazing we love you we'll see you
next week
peace